Apple's iOS 10 is coming this fall and
it's coming with some big changes and
some small ones first series going to be
a lot more useful now since developers
can integrate the AI into their apps hey
Siri call me a car so I can stop doing
this stand up you'll be able to do more
wherever you're going with the new more
open Maps and if somebody asks you for
information Siri can help you respond
nice job AI am i message is gonna be a
lot more useful to bigger emoji an
invisible ink will make talking more fun
and more discreet but the real deal is
that iMessage is going to be an actual
platform now complete with square
payments and rich links for video and
music speaking of music Apple music is
much cleaner and more personalized
you'll even get a daily playlist of
tunes ala
Spotify discover news is getting a
similar makeover plus support for paid
subscriptions notifications are going to
be a lot more responsive and cleaner -
and you can interact with notifications
and widgets to do a lot without ever
opening apps it's all about faster
interactions in iOS 10 the Photos app is
catching up to Google but with one big
difference all the sorting and
face-recognition will take place locally
instead of in the cloud perfect for your
sensitive pictures the phone you know
the part you talk into is getting
voicemail transcription and much better
integration with calls from other apps
now what wasn't announced is just as
important in iOS 10 there are lots of
little features but the best news is the
tips calculator and more than a dozen
other preloaded apps you can finally
delete those five forever stocks it's
all coming this fall but if you can't
wait there's a fella preview out right
now but you should wait and in the
meantime maybe say a nice long goodbye
to games